En 1517, un jeune moine allemand a remué le continent européen,
non par son intelligence, par sa force ou son courage,
mais par la redécouverte du plus beau des messages.
Je parle de l'évangile de Jésus-Christ.
Ce message qu'a redécouvert Martin Luther
peut se résumer par le fait que le juste vivra par la foi.
Ce fut le début de ce que l'on a appelé la réformation.
Et si vous êtes dans cette église, vous êtes peut-être familier
avec certains de ces réformateurs.
Jean Calvin, John Knox, Ulrich Zingli, Philippe Mélanton, Guillaume Farel,
Thomas Kramer, pour n'en citer que quelques-uns.
Qui plus est, vous êtes encore plus familier
avec les doctrines bibliques qui ont accompagné la réformation.
Je parle du salut et pas la grâce seule,
pas la foi seule, en Jésus-Christ seule,
selon l'Écriture seule,
pour la gloire de Dieu seul.
Ce que l'on appelle les cinq solaires de la réforme protestante.
Les méveillements suscités par ces vérités retrouvées
étaient tels que l'on en parlait en employant le vocable
« post tenebras lux »
pour signifier qu'après l'obscurité du Moyen-Âge religieux
venait la lumière de la parole de Dieu redécouverte.
Toutefois, au cœur de cette réformation
se trouvait une vérité plus grande
et encore plus importante
qui est celle de l'adoration authentique.
Pour les réformateurs,
l'adoration authentique centrée sur Dieu
est la finalité de notre vie
et reflète le but ultime de la réforme.
Les réformateurs avaient donc discerné
le véritable danger de la corruption
des l'Églises catholiques romaines.
Ils savaient bien là où se jouait
la bataille décisive.
La question de la véritable adoration
imprégnait donc toutes les vérités
qu'ils avaient redécouvertes.
Nous qui sommes 500 années maintenant
loin de cette réformation,
nous devions nous arrêter
et y réfléchir.
Quelle est la finalité du salut ?
Pour quelles raisons
Dieu sauve-t-il des hommes ?
Cela devient encore plus clair
en nous demandant
quel est le but fondamental
de notre existence.
Avec le catéchisme de Westminster,
nous pouvons répondre que
c'est de glorifier Dieu
et de trouver notre joie
en Lui pour toujours.
Oui, mes frères et sœurs,
nous avons été créés
pour vivre dans une communion
étroite et merveilleuse
en servant Dieu.
Et notre salut en Christ
n'échappe pas à ce but.
Ce salut est le moyen
voulu par Dieu trinitaire
pour accomplir cette vocation
chez ses élus.
Et c'est ce que notre frère
nous a rappelé ce matin
en notre réduction,
aujourd'hui.
En tant qu'être humain,
au cœur de notre essence
se trouve cette vérité.
Nous sommes essentiellement
des adorateurs.
Dieu a effectivement
mis en nous
la pensée de l'éternité.
Ne pas l'adorer
serait raté
la cible de notre humanité.
Voilà ce que les réformateurs
avaient compris.
Ils se sont attélés
à défendre
au péril de leur vie
cette vérité.
En nous plongeant
donc ce matin
sur cette célèbre rencontre
entre Jésus
et la femme samaritaine,
nous ressentons
le poids de ce sujet.
Quelle adoration authentique.
Sujet que les réformateurs
ont refusé d'ignorer.
Comme eux,
nous pouvons nous rendre compte
de la centralité
de ce sujet
dans le propos
que notre Seigneur
tient devant
cette femme samaritaine.
Ce sont là
les adorateurs
que le Père recherche.
Ce sont là
les adorateurs
que le Père demande.
Alors,
qu'est-ce que
la véritable adoration ?
Qui en est l'objet ?
Comment devrait-on
rendre cette adoration ?
Comment ?
Ces questions
apparaissent en filigrane
dans les dialogues
entre Jésus
et Nicodème
au chapitre 3
et entre Jésus
et la femme samaritaine
au chapitre 4.
Rappelons-nous,
Nicodème est le docteur
d'Israël.
Il est au sommet
de la religion juive.
Il coche
toutes les cases.
la samaritaine
est socialement
marginalisée,
moralement brisée
et ignorante
des choses de Dieu.
Deux positions sociales,
deux manières
d'approcher Dieu,
deux êtres sincères,
deux êtres perdus.
toutefois,
un même point
au cœur
de cette discussion
théologique,
le salut
en Jésus,
seul moyen
d'accès
à la véritable
adoration.
Regardons le contexte
de cette rencontre
avec la femme samaritaine.
Notre Seigneur,
en route vers la Galilée,
devait passer
par la Samarie.
Fatigué par ce voyage,
Jésus s'assit
près d'un puits
appelé le puits
de Jacob.
Une femme samaritaine
y vint puiser de l'eau.
Le Seigneur
de tout
lui demande
à boire.
L'humilité
de notre Dieu.
Incroyable.
Supprise par cette demande,
elle lui rappela
qu'il était un juif,
car les juifs
n'avaient pas
de relation
avec les samaritaines.
Notre Seigneur
se mit alors
à lui parler
de quelque chose
de plus profond,
le don de Dieu.
La réponse
de la Samaritaine
laissa croire
qu'elle n'avait pas
saisi
le sens profond
de ses paroles,
comme Nicodème
au chapitre 3,
rappelez-vous.
Le Seigneur
devint plus explicite
sur ce qu'il entendait
par le don de Dieu,
lui révélant
qu'il est lui-même
la promesse centrale
des révélations
de Dieu.
Ayant désormais
toute son attention,
Jésus mit en lumière
la réalité
de son péché.
La femme,
sans nier la vérité
des paroles de Jésus,
reconnue
qu'il était prophète.
400 ans
sont prophètes
en Israël.
Dès qu'elle a entendu
cela,
elle a reconnu
tout de suite
qu'il était prophète.
c'est alors
qu'elle interrogea
sur une question
au cœur
de nombreux débats
entre juifs
et samaritains.
La question
de l'authenticité
de l'adoration.
La femme samaritaine
fut comme réveillée
pour considérer
sérieusement
la vraie religion.
C'est ça
le contexte.
Voilà le contexte
dans lequel
cette péricorde
que nous allons
exposer se situe.
Le contexte
de l'adoration.
La femme samaritaine
maintenant éveillée
à la gravité
de son péché
demande
ce qui est nécessaire
pour connaître
le véritable salut.
Et pour exposer
au mieux
ces passages,
nous allons considérer
cette vérité
centrale.
Jésus-Christ
est au cœur
de la véritable adoration
afin que nous
réjouissions
de l'intimité
avec Dieu.
En d'autres mots,
la communion authentique
avec le Père
est portée
sur la personne
du Christ
afin que nous
trouvions
plaisir
en lui
pour toujours.
Nous allons donc
dans une première partie
aborder
l'adoration
au cœur
de la vie
des hommes,
des êtres humains.
Versets 19 à 21.
Puis,
en deuxième partie,
nous traiterons
de l'adoration
du seul vrai Dieu
selon Jésus-Christ.
Versets 22 à 23.
Et enfin,
nous terminerons
par considérer
l'adoration
chrétienne
en conformité
avec le caractère
du seul vrai Dieu.
Verset 24.
Mais avant,
avant que nous puissions
commencer notre exposition,
j'aimerais que nous ne
perdions pas de vue
un point essentiel.
il y a un grand sentiment
d'inadéquation
pour chacun de nous
lorsque nous parlons
de la véritable adoration.
Ce sujet
est si glorieux
et nous sommes
si disloqués
qu'il ne peut
que nous rappeler
notre indignité
et notre gâchis.
il y a d'innombrables
raisons
de nous taper
la poitrine
et de nous lamenter
lorsque nous en parlons.
Toutefois,
frères et sœurs,
cette même main
qui nous afflige
devant un tel sujet
est la même main
qui nous a sauvés
en Jésus-Christ.
Il y a une telle
espérance en Christ
pour nous,
une telle provision
d'espoir
que nous ne devrions
pas baisser les bras
ni même désespérés.
Je vous prie
donc bien aimé
que tout au long
de cette prédication
nous ne perdions pas
de vue le privilège
qui est le nôtre.
Dieu sait
de quoi nous sommes formés
et cela ne l'a pas
découragé
à venir sauver
des personnes comme nous.
Alors,
amons-nous de courage
et avec un cœur
plein d'humilité
inclinons les oreilles
de nos cœurs
pour écouter
notre Seigneur
modélé,
notre compréhension
et notre pratique
de la véritable adoration.
Vous êtes prêts ?
On peut y aller ensemble ?
Abordons la première partie
de cette prédication
qui s'intitule
« Qui traitera
de l'adoration
au cœur de la vie
des êtres humains. »
Relisons ensemble
le verset 19 à 21.
Seigneur lui dit
la femme
« Je vois que tu es prophète.
Nos pères ont adoré
sur cette montagne
et vous dites-vous
que le lieu
où il faut adorer
est à Jérusalem. »
Femme lui dit Jésus
« Crois-moi,
l'heure vient
où ce ne sera
ni sur cette montagne
ni à Jérusalem
que vous adorerez le Père. »
Le Dieu de la Bible
a créé
toutes choses
pour un but.
Tout ce qui existe
Et malgré que notre monde
soit frappé
par les effets
de la chute,
toutes ces choses
poursuivent
la raison pour laquelle
elles ont été créées.
Que vous preniez le soleil,
la lune,
les montagnes,
les plaines,
les vallées,
les océans,
les animaux,
pour n'en citer
que quelques-uns,
tous ont été créés
par un Dieu sage
et saint
pour un but.
Aucun ne se dérobe
au dessein
pour lequel
il a été créé.
Et même bien
que le péché
ait altéré
la réalisation
de leurs objectifs
initiaux,
ils finissent toujours
par accomplir
le but
de leur création.
Toutefois,
si toute la création
obéit au dessein
de Dieu,
il serait incohérent
que l'homme,
même dessus,
qui est le sommet
de cette création,
soit dépourvu
d'un but.
Il en est donc
de même
pour les êtres humains.
Nous sommes par nature
des êtres
orientés vers l'adoration.
Nous ne pouvons pas
ne pas adorer.
Cela veut dire que,
quel que soit l'endroit
où vous trouverez
un être humain,
vous le verrez
mettre sa confiance
et chérie,
avec une intensité
particulière,
quelque chose
ou quelqu'un.
Et cela
parce que cette personne
ou cette chose
aura à ses yeux
un grand prix,
une valeur inestimable.
cette tendance
ne se trouve pas
chez quelques personnes
comme certaines
personnes veulent
nous faire croire.
Non,
c'est un homme spirituel,
nous on n'est pas spirituel.
Non,
tous les hommes
ont ce désir,
ont cette inclinaison
envers l'adoration.
Paul,
debout au milieu
de l'aéropage,
dit,
Athénien,
je vous trouve
à tout point de vue
extrêmement religieux.
En effet,
en parcourant
votre ville
et en examinant
les objets
de votre culte,
j'ai même découvert
un hôtel
avec cette inscription
à un dieu inconnu.
Acte 17
Dans chaque peuple,
vous trouverez
cette nature
inclinée
envers l'adoration.
Et nous voyons
la même chose
entre le peuple juif
et le peuple samaritain.
Le débat
de l'adoration
faisait rage.
Chacun s'accusait
mutuellement.
Non seulement
il s'accusait
de ne pas vraiment
adorer,
mais aussi
de ne pas le faire
à l'endroit
prescrit par Dieu.
La rencontre
de Jésus
avec la femme
samaritaine
telle que rapportée
dans l'évangile
de Jean
est l'un des passages
les plus instructifs
des Écritures
sur le thème
de l'adoration.
Rappelons-nous
que les samaritains
étaient les descendants
de l'ancien royaume
d'Israël du Nord
qui s'étaient unis
par mariage
à des populations
non israélites
installées
en terre promise
par l'Empire
assyrien
après 722
avant Jésus-Christ.
A l'époque
du ministère
Thérèse de Jésus,
ces samaritains
avaient développé
une théologie
particulière.
Ils considéraient
le mont Garazim
comme le véritable
lieu d'adoration.
Les juifs
et les samaritains
se sont violemment
affrontés
pour cela.
Les juifs
se croyaient
supérieurs aux samaritains
et les méprisaient.
Ils estimaient
que les samaritains
avaient compromis
leur identité juive.
Les samaritains,
quant à eux,
se croyaient
supérieurs aux juifs
car ils affirmaient
adorer
au véritable lieu
choisi par Dieu
contrairement
aux juifs.
Ils accusaient
les juifs
d'avoir déformé
la révélation de Dieu.
Les samaritains
disaient,
entre autres,
vous les juifs,
vous adorez
à Sion
et à Jérusalem.
Ce n'est pas là-bas
que Dieu nous a dit
d'adorer.
vous n'avez pas compris
le message de Dieu.
La femme samaritaine
pouvait dire cela
à Jésus
car les samaritains
avaient rejeté
toute la révélation
des Écritures
excepté
les cinq premiers livres
de Genèse
à Détéronome.
Il en résulta
une rivalité amère
entre les samaritains
et les juifs.
Nous voyons donc
comment le besoin
d'adorer
est enraciné
dans le cœur
de ces deux peuples.
Et nous retrouvons
ce même besoin
chez tous les autres peuples,
chez tous les hommes.
Même nous le retrouvons
chez nous.
Pensez avant
votre conversion
et regardez
après votre conversion.
On adore tous.
c'est ce que Jean Calvin
a appelé
le sensus divinitatis,
c'est-à-dire
le sentiment
de la divinité
dont Dieu
a doté
toute l'humanité.
Nous sommes
des êtres
profondément religieux.
Toutes les formes
d'idolâtrie
les plus flagrantes
et les multitudes
de religions
en témoignent.
ainsi,
quelqu'un
a affirmé
que
l'homme
ne poursuit
rien
avec
autant
d'acharnement
et de souffrance
que la nécessité
d'adorer
quelque chose.
Cette vocation
religieuse
est gravée
à jamais
dans le cœur
humain.
Elle est
dans le cœur
de chacun
de nous
sans exception.
Sans exception.
Mes frères et sœurs,
nous sommes appelés
à l'adoration.
C'est notre
plus grande vocation.
Mais voilà,
cette vocation
dans la révélation
progressive
de notre Dieu
a pu être
manifeste
en divers endroits
bien précis.
Des endroits
désignés
par Dieu lui-même.
Dieu se plaisait
à prescrire
un endroit
où il se
présenterait
à son peuple
afin de communier
avec lui.
C'était le tabernacle
ou le temple,
etc.
Mais ici,
au moment
où notre Seigneur
parle avec
cette femme
samaritaine,
il appelle
l'attention
de la femme
et la nôtre
aussi
afin que nous
sachions
qu'un temps
vient
où l'adoration
ne sera plus
une question
de lieu.
Et c'est le cas
aujourd'hui.
Comprinons bien,
à ce stade
même
dans l'ancienne
dispensation,
l'adoration
dépassait
le simple cadre
du lieu.
L'aspect formel
de l'adoration
n'a jamais primé
sur l'attitude
du cœur.
Jamais.
Ce n'est pas
que les juifs
partaient
avec les animaux,
ils se réveillaient
le matin,
j'ai péché,
je tue l'animal
et c'est bon,
je suis pardonné.
Non,
ce n'était pas
la formalité.
Pensons à Abel
et Caïn
et leurs offrandes
car cette histoire
reflète
que le formalisme
seul ne suffit pas
devant un Dieu saint.
Pensons au livre
de Samuel
lorsque l'Éternel
rappelle qu'il ne
considère pas
ce que l'homme
considère
mais qu'il regarde
au cœur.
Pensons à l'homme
selon le cœur
de Dieu,
David,
lorsqu'il nous dit
que les sacrifices
qui sont agréables
à Dieu,
c'est un cœur
brisé,
un esprit
brisé.
Pensons encore
au salmiste
qui aimerait savoir
si quelqu'un peut monter
à la montagne
de l'Éternel.
La réponse
est sans équivoque,
seulement celui
qui a les mains
et le cœur
pu.
Enfin,
pensons au prophète
Esaïe
qui rapporte
les paroles
de l'Éternel
qui révélait
que son peuple
honorait des lèvres
mais son cœur
était si éloigné.
Vous voyez,
frères et sœurs,
notre Dieu
n'a jamais été intéressé
par une adoration
éloignée du cœur.
Notre Seigneur
conduit donc
la femme samaritaine
à croire fermement
que l'adoration
n'a jamais été
seulement une question
de lieu.
Cependant,
il arrive une heure,
l'heure de l'Évangile
où les hommes
s'effaceront
pour laisser place
à la lumière.
Et c'est cet évangile
dans lequel
les anges
désirplongaient
leur regard
comme Pierre
nous le dit.
L'heure est venue
où l'exposition
de la glorieuse
manifestation
de la grâce
de Dieu
ne se voit plus
sur une montagne
mais au travail
d'individus
qui sont
de partout
du monde.
Ils se rassemblent
pour adorer en Église
afin que
les dominations
et les autorités
dans les lieux célestes
connaissent aujourd'hui
par l'Église
la sagesse infinie
variée de Dieu.
Éphésiens 3
Le pasteur
de Sirayl disait
« L'ancienne dispensation
sous laquelle
il fallait se rendre
trois fois par an
à Jérusalem
pour assister
aux fêtes
et adorer
dans le temple
allaient disparaître.
Toutes les questions
sur la sainteté supérieure
de Samarie
ou de Jérusalem
seraient bientôt
réglées.
Une Église
allait être fondée
dont les membres
auraient accès
au Père
partout
sans avoir besoin
de temples
de prêtres
de sacrifices
ou d'hôtels
pour approcher Dieu.
Voilà cette
merveilleuse
vérité
mes frères et sœurs.
Elle doit nous protéger
des tentations
de vouloir revenir
aux ombres
ou au Père
comme la Samaritaine
le dit si bien.
nous avons
le plus grand
privilège
d'adorer
le véritable Père
le Père
céleste
comme Jésus
nous le révèle.
Nous devons
considérer
l'accès à ce Père
comme la glorieuse
lumière de l'Évangile
comme ce à quoi
pointait
l'ancienne dispensation.
Soirons donc
encouragés
à ne pas revenir
aux ombres
et si vous vous sentez
tenté d'y retourner
alors écoutez
encore les paroles
du Seigneur Jésus.
L'heure vient
où ce ne sera
ni sur cette montagne
ni à Jérusalem
que vous aurez
adoré le Père.
où allons-nous mettre
notre confiance ?
Où allons-nous mettre
notre confiance
mes frères et soeurs ?
Dans les paroles
du Christ
ou dans notre héritage ?
ou dans nos coutumes ?
Ou dans nos habitudes
même enracinées
dans la Bible ?
Ainsi, après avoir traité
en première partie
l'adoration au cœur
de la vie des hommes
nous allons aborder
en deuxième partie
l'adoration du seul vrai Dieu
selon Jésus-Christ.
Je vous invite
à relire avec moi
les versets 22 à 23.
Vous adorez
ce que vous ne connaissez pas.
Nous, nous adorons
ce que nous connaissons
car le salut vient des Juifs
mais l'heure vient
et elle est déjà venue
où les vrais adorateurs
adoreront le Père
en esprit et en vérité
car ce sont là
les adorateurs
que le Père demande
ou que le Père recherche.
Nous avons jusqu'ici
parlé de l'adoration
qu'on manquait
dans la nature
même de l'homme
et du fait
que l'adoration
a toujours été
plus qu'une question
de lieu.
Mais en considérant
particulièrement
les versets 22 à 23
nous pouvons remarquer
que notre Seigneur
porte une appréciation
claire
sur l'adoration
des Samaritains
et il affirme
sans embâge
que le salut
est au cœur
de l'adoration
authentique.
En effet,
les Samaritains
en décidant
de ne choisir
que le Pentateuch
c'est-à-dire
les cinq livres
allant de Genèse
au Détéronome
se sont privés
de la révélation
complète de Dieu.
Ils rejetaient
en effet
les Sommes
et les Prophètes.
Les Samaritains
ne pouvaient montrer
aucune autorité
scripturée
ni révélation
de Dieu
qui sanctionnaient
leur adoration.
Tout ce qu'ils faisaient
était pure invention
humaine,
jamais officiellement
autorisé
ni agréé
par Dieu.
Les religions
étaient un syncrétisme,
c'est-à-dire
un mélange
du judaïsme
avec les religions
païennes.
Ils n'avaient
aucune garantie
que leurs prières,
leurs louanges,
leurs offrandes
étaient acceptées
par Dieu.
Aucune garantie.
Le jugement
de notre Seigneur
sur une telle attitude
est sans appel.
Vous adorez
ce que vous ne connaissez pas.
Les Samaritains
avaient rejeté
une grande partie
des oracles de Dieu
et s'étaient égarés
loin de la véritable
adoration
que l'Éternel
avait prescrite.
Mon peuple
est détruit
parce qu'il lui manque
la connaissance.
Puisque tu as
rejeté la connaissance,
je te rejetterai
et tu seras
dépouillé
de mon sacerdoce.
Osé 4
C'est une terrible
désillusion
pour la Samaritaine
et pour son peuple.
Ils avaient été
zélés
pour adorer Dieu
mais sans intelligence.
Ils étaient
comme les insensés
qui meurent
par défaut
de raison
comme nous le dit
l'auteur des Proverbes.
Malheureusement,
aujourd'hui aussi,
la plupart des églises
marchent en imitant
les Samaritains
dans la méconnaissance
de l'objet
de l'adoration
qui est Dieu,
le Père.
Notre frère
Paul Washer
disait
« Le dimanche matin
est le moment
le plus idolat
de la semaine
parce que la plupart
de ceux
qui adorent Dieu
adorent un Dieu
qu'ils ne connaissent pas.
Ils adorent un Dieu
qui ressemble plus
au Père Noël
qu'au Dieu des Écritures.
Ils adorent un Dieu
qui est le plus produit
de leur imagination. »
Voilà un triste constat
pour l'église
du XXIe siècle.
Voilà un triste constat
qui doit nous faire
taper la poitrine.
Les Samaritains
savaient cependant
que le Messie
avait été promis
bien qu'il n'y ait
retenu que le Pentateuch.
Rappelez-vous,
ils avaient Genèse,
Genèse 3, 15,
ils pouvaient lire cela.
Ils savaient.
Ils avaient
les livres de Moïse
qui disaient
que Moïse attendait
un plus grand
que lui.
Donc,
ils pouvaient
attendre
quand même
le Messie.
Ils pouvaient
y trouver
les promesses
messianiques.
C'est pour cela
que la Samaritaine,
la femme Samaritaine,
savait que le Messie
devait venir.
Mais voilà,
les années
de religion fausse
et d'immoralité
avaient fini
par rabaisser
et dégrader
la société Samaritaine.
Ils avaient
de ce fait même
nier le rôle
assigné
par Dieu
au peuple juif.
Frères et sœurs,
est-ce que vous
entrevoyez
un tout petit peu
les conséquences graves
de choisir pour soi
ce que la parole dit
et de rejeter
le reste ?
Regardez aux Samaritains.
Voilà la conséquence
de faire cela.
Toutes les écoutures
sont inspirées,
sont utiles pour nous.
Il ne faut rejeter
aucune de ces paroles,
mais les comprendre,
les interpréter
à l'aune
de notre Seigneur
Jésus-Christ.
Mais Jésus
l'affirme clairement.
Le salut
vient des Juifs,
femmes samaritaines.
Jamais il n'a été dit
que le salut
viendrait des Samarites,
mais le salut
vient des Juifs.
Et là,
nous sommes devant
la grande vérité
de toutes les révélations
de Dieu
à l'homme
en tout temps.
Cette révélation
a été donnée
particulièrement
aux Juifs.
Il faut le reconnaître.
Jésus le reconnaît.
Dieu avait prévu
de toute éternité
de se choisir
un peuple
et par ce peuple
d'enseigner au monde
la voie du salut.
Il avait prévu
de préparer
le sauveur
qui viendrait vivre
et mourir
pour son peuple
afin de le conduire
à la véritable adoration.
Mais lorsque les temps
ont été accomplis,
Dieu a envoyé
son fils,
né d'une femme,
né sous la loi,
afin qu'il racheta
ceux qui étaient
sous la loi
afin que nous recevions
l'adoption.
Galate 4
Le peuple juif
serait donc,
servirait donc,
pardon,
de lumière au monde
et tout le système
religieux
qui s'y trouvait
servait
à dessein
pour la réalisation
du plan rédempteur
de Dieu.
J'établis,
je t'établis,
pardon,
pour être la lumière
des nations
pour porter mon salut
jusqu'aux extrémités
de la terre.
Le prophète Esaïe
au chapitre 49.
Il nous faut quand même
souligner
que le témoignage
rendu à la vérité générale
du système religieux
juif
est frappant.
Il est vraiment frappant.
Bien que corrompus
et méchants
que fussent
les scribes
et les pharisiens,
Jésus déclare
que la religion juive
est vraie
et elle est scripturaire.
Mes frères et sœurs,
c'est la triste preuve
qu'une église
peut conserver
un credo saint,
une confession
de foi authentique
et pourtant
être sur le chemin
de la destruction.
Ils avaient la vérité
avec eux.
Ils avaient les credos,
ils avaient les scribes,
les pharisiens,
les docteurs de la loi.
Jésus dit
oui, c'est vrai,
vous les avez.
Mais vous faites
fausse route.
Toutefois,
pour Jésus,
une ère arrive
et même
est déjà présente
où l'adoration
ne sera plus indiquée
en pointant à Sion
ou à Jérusalem
ou au temple,
le tabernacle,
les rites,
les cérémonies
ou les rituels.
Non.
Jésus annonce
un temps
qui est déjà en marche
au moment où il parle
où l'esprit de Dieu
aura été répandu
avec une telle intensité
que l'on dépassera
les formes mécaniques
du culte
pour accéder
au culte spirituel
où l'on se réjouira
en Jésus-Christ
plutôt qu'en
notre nationalité.
Non.
En rien,
je mets ma confiance.
En sa croix
et en Jésus-Ceul,
je m'accroche.
L'adoration
de l'Ancien Testament
profondément intérieure
et spirituelle
se revêtait toutefois
dans son expression extérieure
d'un cadre cérémoniel
chargé de la loi mosaïque.
Celle du Nouveau Testament
est quant à elle
intérieure
et spirituelle
en le Messie promenant.
Et oui,
c'est une adoration spirituelle
et véritable
médiée par le Christ
et guidée par sa parole.
Car c'est lui le chemin,
la vérité
et la vie.
Il est cette vérité
qui rend libre
tous les hommes
et qui les sanctifie.
Quiconque est de la vérité
écoute sa voix.
Car le Christ
est la révélation
ultime de Dieu.
Après avoir autrefois,
à plusieurs reprises
et de plusieurs manières
parlé à nos pères
par les prophètes.
Dieu dans ces derniers temps
nous a parlé par le Fils
qu'il a établi
héritier de toutes choses
par lesquelles
il a aussi créé le monde
et qui étant
le reflet de sa gloire
est l'empreinte
de sa personne
et soutenant
toutes choses
par sa parole puissante.
Hébreu 1.
On n'a pas besoin
de commenter celle.
Le reflet de sa gloire.
Il est la personne
désignée par Dieu lui-même.
Ce n'est donc pas une nouveauté
en termes d'adoration.
Ce n'est pas une nouveauté
que Jésus est en train de dire
à la femme samaritaine.
Il y a quelque chose de nouveau,
tu n'as rien compris
et tout.
Non.
C'est un puissant
et un massif réveil
que le Christ
et le Saint-Esprit
apportent
sur le peuple de Dieu.
une intensité
de rafraîchissement spirituel
jamais vue auparavant
car je reprendrai
des eaux
sur le sol altéré
et des ruisseaux
sur la terre desséchée.
Je reprendrai
mon esprit
sur ta race
et ma bénédiction
sur tes rejetons.
Esaïe 44, verset 3.
C'est une adoration
pleinement vivante,
universelle
et intérieure
en Christ
par son esprit.
Ce sont donc
de tels adorateurs
que le Père recherche.
Et il y a une chose
qui est très importante
à comprendre.
C'est Dieu
qui cherche les adorateurs.
Il ne regarde pas
au hasard
qui l'adorera
aujourd'hui.
Qui est venu
à l'église
pour m'adorer aujourd'hui?
Où ils sont
mes adorateurs?
Non.
C'est lui
qui part activement
à la recherche
des adorateurs.
Il ne se contente pas
d'attendre
que les hommes
viennent à lui.
Il les cherche
et vous savez quoi
frère et soeur?
Il ne revient jamais
sans les avoir
tous trouvés.
Il ne revient jamais
sans les avoir
tous trouvés.
La preuve,
vous êtes là,
les adorateurs du Christ
par son esprit.
Vous qui rendez
un culte à Dieu,
un culte qui lui
est agréable.
Il est allé vous chercher.
Il vous a ramené.
C'est l'heure
où le Père
a adorné
de toute éternité,
de rassembler
du monde
un groupe
de vrais adorateurs
spirituels.
Il les cherche,
il les rassemble
avec une compassion
extrême
et une volonté
infinie
de sauver
les âmes.
C'est une vérité
spécialement
encourageante
pour la femme
samaritaine.
Est-elle prête
à être
une adoratrice
spirituelle?
Est-elle prête
à vouloir
adorer Dieu
en esprit
et en vérité?
Mes frères et sœurs,
nous n'insisterons
jamais assez
sur le fait
que les véritables
adorateurs
du seul vrai Dieu
sont ceux
qui sont nés
par la puissance
récréatrice
de son Saint-Esprit.
Ils étaient
autrefois
morts dans leurs péchés
et leurs offenses,
mais Dieu
qui est riche
en miséricorde
les a rendus
à la vie.
C'est ce que Jésus
a enseigné
à Nicodème
en Jean 3
et en Jean 4
notre Seigneur
nous fait une application
glorieuse
de ce qu'il a dit
à Nicodème.
Prenez le temps
chez vous
de relire
Jean 3 et Jean 4
vous verrez.
En effet,
ceux qui font
cette expérience
de récréation
par le Saint-Esprit
ont pour la
toute première fois
de leur résistance
la toute première fois
toutes les autres fois
il n'y avait rien
c'était aucune adoration
soyez-en su
soyez-en assurés
jamais un homme
ne peut adorer Dieu
sans être récréé
par Dieu
à cause de son péché
mort dans le péché
c'est impossible
d'adorer le seul vrai Dieu
la première fois
que nous tous
avons adoré
véritablement
le seul vrai Dieu
c'était lorsque
le Saint-Esprit
est venu
changer notre cœur
de pierre
en cœur de chair
et nous a donné accès
au trône de la grâce.
ceux qui ont fait
cette expérience
de récréation
par le Saint-Esprit
pour la toute première fois
de leur résistance
véritablement
ont adoré
le seul vrai Dieu
leurs louanges
et leurs prières
montent
au trône de la grâce
et sont présentés
et accueillis
comme un parfum
de bonne odeur
devant
leur Père Céleste
car à tous ceux
qui l'ont reçu
à ceux qui croient
en son nom
elle a donné le pouvoir
de devenir
enfant de Dieu
lesquels sont nés
non du sang
ni de la volonté
de la chair
de l'homme
mais de Dieu
mais de Yahweh
de l'Éternel
du Père Céleste
du Dieu Glorieux
exalté par les anges
le majestueux Dieu
qui habite
une lumière inaccessible
prend plaisir
à écouter leurs prières
car elles sont
toutes médiées
par le Fils
de son amour
bien-aimé
le Christ
lui-même
reçoit
leur adoration
avec tendresse
lui seul
médiateur
entre Dieu
et les hommes
et les apporte
à son Père
et leur Père
qui dans une joie
indescriptible
par des mots humains
les reçoit
tous sans exception
Dieu prend plaisir
à recevoir
vos prières
vos louanges
votre adoration
médiée par Christ
parce que vous êtes
unis à lui
et il ne les regarde
pas avec des dents
il ne les regarde
il les reçoit
tous sans exception
alors mes chers
sommes-nous
de tels adorateurs
que le Père cherche
est-ce que nos dispositions
de cœur
ont été changées
par Dieu
sous la puissance
de son Saint-Esprit
est-ce le cas
est-ce cette réalité
pour nous
dans nos vies
si oui
alors
rejouissons-nous
le Père célèbre
prend plaisir
en de tels adorateurs
car n'oublions pas
sans la foi
il est impossible
de lui être agréable
mais pour ceux
qui disent
Christian
je ne pense pas
être un véritable
adorateur
de Yahweh
de l'éternel
frère et soeur
à ces personnes
je veux dire
plaidez avec Dieu
lutter avec lui
Jacob l'a fait
suppliez-le
de vous sauver
tournez-vous
vers son Messie
écoutez
il avait promis
d'envoyer son Messie
afin qu'il porte
les péchés
du nombre à pécheurs
ce Messie est venu
il a vécu
la vie parfaite
que vous et moi
ne pourrions vivre
et il est allé
à la croix
il a été puni
pour nos péchés
il a été frappé
par Dieu
pour nos iniquités
il a pu à Dieu
de le briser
par la souffrance
il est mort
et il a été mis
au tambour
mais le troisième jour
il est ressuscité
des morts
prouvant ainsi
que la mort
n'a plus de pouvoir
et qu'il est victorieux
pour toujours
il est monté
aux cieux
le Messie de Dieu
revêtu d'une nature humaine
qui connaît
vos douleurs
vos souffrances
intercède
jour après jour
continuellement
auprès de son Père
pour le salut
des perdus
de ceux que
le Père lui a donné
avant la fondation du monde
et qu'est-ce qui se passe
Dieu se plaît
à rassasier
ses regards
à cause du travail
de son âme
comment il ne vous donnera
pas à Christ
souvenez à lui
arrêtez de ne pas croire cela
frères et sœurs
Dieu va rassasier
les regards
de son fils
si vous venez à lui
il ne vous mettra pas dehors
c'est la plus belle des promesses
assurez que
il vous accueillera
alors
jetez vous sur ce Messie
vous qui doutiez
rappelez-vous
que c'est lui
qui offre l'eau de vie
et quiconque
on boira
n'aura jamais soif
cette eau
deviendra
une source
qui jaillera
de la terre
passera les cieux
et ira
jusqu'à dans l'éternité
voilà cette eau
avez-vous soif
buvez cette eau
si vous ne le connaissez pas
vous ne payez pas
vous buvez gratuitement
buvez cette eau
je vous supplie
vos âmes ont de la valeur
auprès de Dieu
il vous a créé pour adorer
nous arrivons maintenant
à la troisième
et dernière partie
de ce serment
après avoir vu
que l'adoration
est au coeur
de la vie des hommes
puis l'adoration
du seul vrai Dieu
selon Jésus Christ
considérons à présent
l'adoration chrétienne
à la lumière
de la nature
du caractère
à la lumière
des attributs
de Dieu lui-même
relisons ensemble
le verset 24
Dieu est esprit
il faut que ceux
qui l'adorent
l'adorent en esprit
et en vérité
nous arrivons à ce moment
de la discussion
entre Jésus
et la femme samaritaine
où notre Seigneur
lui révèle
la véritable nature
de Dieu
c'est l'une des déclarations
les plus élevées
et précises
sur la nature
de qui Dieu est
dans toute la Bible
elle nous est donnée
par qui ?
par le Seigneur
Jésus Christ lui-même
et rappelez-vous
ce qu'il nous dit
personne ne connaît
le Père
si ce n'est le Fils
et celui à qui le Fils
veut le révéler
le seul fait
que Jésus soit en train
de révéler cela
à la femme samaritaine
est qu'il conduit
à un but
il veut la sauver
est-ce qu'il a été
empêché de la sauver ?
non
vous connaissez l'histoire
qui a suivi
un réveil massif
qui est arrivé
alors
en pointant
en regard
en regardant
en pointant nos yeux
envers les attributs
la personne de Dieu
il y a un grand
encouragement
pour nous
mon Seigneur révèle
maintenant le Père
à la femme samaritaine
Dieu
est Esprit
qu'est-ce que Jésus
voulait dire
par cette déclaration ?
qu'est-ce qu'il révélait
à nous aussi
par ces mots ?
mes frères
mes sœurs
définis pleinement
cette expression
dépasse notre
compréhension humaine
l'idée principale
ici est probablement
que
Dieu est immatériel
il n'habite pas
dans les temples
faits de mains d'hommes
il n'est pas
absent dans un lieu
lorsqu'il est présent
dans un autre lieu
aucun lieu
de l'univers
ne saurait le contenir
il est omniprésent
il voit tout ce qui se passe
il est Esprit
souverain
parfait
maître
de toutes choses
c'est le Dieu
invisible
le Dieu
éternel
simple
dans sa simplicité
divine
et le Dieu
infini
en plus du fait
que Dieu soit Esprit
nous sommes invités
par les écritures
à l'adorer
en lui rendant un culte
qui lui soit agréable
et cette adoration
ce culte
que nous devons lui rendre
il doit se faire
en Esprit
et en vérité
sa nature
recouvre
l'adoration
que nous lui devons
il n'y a rien
qui devait lui être rendu
comme honneur
louange
et reconnaissance
en dehors de qui il est
et de ce qu'il fait
mais bien aimé
sachant que la profondeur
de la compréhension
de qui Dieu est
va nourrir
la profondeur
de notre adoration
plus vous vous émerveillez
de ses attributs
de son caractère
de sa nature
de qui il est
plus votre adoration
sera nourrie
en retour
c'est pour cela
que nous devons
chérir ce que révèlent
les écritures sur Dieu
de telle sorte
que
ce que nous apprenions
de lui
affecte nos pensées
notre coeur
et nos paroles
car nous sommes appelés
à l'aimer
de tout notre coeur
de toute notre pensée
de toute notre force
il faut que ce que nous
savons de Dieu
affecte non seulement
notre adoration
mais aussi nos vies
nos mariages
nos amitiés
notre éthique
notre vision du monde
notre manière
d'élever nos enfants
de traiter son église
et de considérer
nos frères et soeurs
notre manière
de nous rapporter
à ceux qui nous
persécutent
maudissent
à ceux qui nous
rejettent
à W. Tozer
disait
à Justit
ce qui vient
à notre esprit
quand nous pensons
à Dieu
est la chose
la plus importante
à propos
de nous
voyez-vous
mes frères et soeurs
comment sa nature
couvre toute l'adoration
que nous lui devons
tout son être
est digne
de louanges
et d'exaltations
tout son être
il est le Dieu esprit
dont la sagesse
est parfaite
car nous trouvons
certainement
la délivrance
auprès de lui
il est le Dieu esprit
dont l'amour
est extraordinaire
car il sauve
ses ennemis
avant même
qu'il ne dépose
les armes
contre lui
il est le Dieu esprit
dont la sainteté
ne laissera pas
impunir le mal
et nous pouvons
lui confier
notre cause
il est le Dieu esprit
qui est humillable
dont nous pouvons
embrasser
toutes les promesses
sans inquiétude
de savoir
s'il changera d'avis
il est le Dieu esprit
qui a condescendu
et qui a pris
notre nature humaine
pour nous justifier
pour nous adopter
pour nous sanctifier
et pour nous glorifier
il est le Dieu esprit
que nous désirons
voir des pains
dans toutes nos prédications
afin que
tous les genoux
fléchissent
et que même
lorsque les hommes
se teraient
et refuseraient
de l'adorer
les pierres
se lèveraient
pour l'exalter
voilà
église
bonne nouvelle
ton Dieu
qui est esprit
c'est ce Dieu
que dépeint la Bible
que vous êtes venus
adorer ce matin
en esprit
et en vérité
il y a véritablement
une adéquation
entre la connaissance
que nous avons
de Dieu
et notre adoration
John Stott
a une manière
très particulière
de le dire
il dit
et je vous invite
à faire attention
à ces mots
notre adoration
est pauvre
parce que
notre connaissance
de Dieu
est pauvre
et notre connaissance
de Dieu
est pauvre
parce que
la prédication
est pauvre
mais lorsque
la parole de Dieu
est exposée
dans toute sa plénitude
l'assemblée
commence à entrevoir
la gloire
du Dieu vivant
et en réponse
elle s'incline
solennellement
avec respect
et une joyeuse admiration
devant son trône
waouh
avec respect
et une joyeuse admiration
devant son trône
la réponse
à l'adoration
de Dieu
la véritable réponse
à l'adoration
à la contemplation
des attributs
des caractères de Dieu
de sa nature
de qui il est
voilà ce que ça provoque
dans un cœur
mes frères et sœurs
ne laissons pas
cette merveilleuse vérité
de côté
ce que Dieu
est en esprit
façonne notre manière
de lui rendre l'honneur
et la louange
c'est de tels adorateurs
que le Père recherche
et rappelez-vous
il ne revient jamais
sans les avoir trouvés
jamais
au début de cette prédication
je vous ai dit que
c'était au cœur
de tout ce que les reformateurs
ont cherché
à faire
à la fin de cette prédication
je vous le rappelle
si le but
de tout ce que nous apprenons
le but de tout ce que nous faisons
n'est pas
pour adorer Dieu
en théologie
comme en pratique
alors nous manquons le but
mais si c'est le cas
alors nous pourrons
une grande espérance
d'aider
des adorateurs
en esprit
et en vérité
je vais vous inviter
à relire ensemble
le verset 19 à 24
pour terminer cette prédication
Seigneur lui dit
la femme samaritaine
je vois que tu es prophète
nos pères ont adoré
sur cette montagne
et vous vous dites
vous vous dites vous
que le lieu où il faut adorer
est à Jérusalem
femme lui dit Jésus
crois moi
l'heure vient
où ce ne sera ni
sur cette montagne
ni à Jérusalem
que vous adorerez le Père
vous adorez
ce que vous ne connaissiez pas
nous nous adorons
ce que nous connaissons
car le salut vient des Juifs
mais l'heure vient
et elle est déjà venue
où les vrais adorateurs
adoreront le Père
en esprit et en vérité
car ce sont là
les adorateurs
que le Père demande
Dieu est esprit
et il faut que
ceux qui l'adorent
l'adorent en esprit
et en vérité
Amen